[Música]
qué les parece si empezamos a hacer un
ejercicio de imaginación
el día de hoy vamos a imaginar que es 20
de julio de 1969
el astronauta james lover habiendo
bebido una botella de champán porque
festejaban la llegada del apolo 11 a la
luna sale al jardín de su casa toma la
mano de su esposa mira el cielo y
reflexiona
cariño a partir de hoy viviremos en un
mundo en el que el hombre ya pisó la
luna y no fue una coincidencia luchamos
nos capacitamos nos preparamos y
llegamos esto vino claro de una gran
inspiración pero a partir de este
momento pisar la luna se ha convertido
en nuestra gran responsabilidad lo vimos
lo que hicimos y lo logramos
neil amstrong había pisado la luna por
primera vez en la historia y el
astronauta james lavelle se preparaba
para el vuelo del apolo 13 que fue
lanzado en el otro set de abril de 1970
porque empiezo con esto porque hay una
gran coincidencia el año pasado en abril
del 2020 se cumplieron 50 históricos
años y el año pasado en abril 20 la
humanidad iniciamos un viaje a un lugar
oscuro forzado y desconocido llamado
pandemia una gran casualidad
pero bueno volvamos a nuestro ejercicio
de imaginación vamos los invito a que
vayamos a cabo cañaveral plataforma 39a
apolo 13
cargado de experiencia de sueños de
trabajo de capacitación de preparación
era el tercer viaje de exploración a la
luna del proyecto apolo
el despegue fue exitoso el apolo 13
llegó al espacio sin ningún contrato de
hecho en la tierra pensaban que iba a
ser un viaje convencional
y más o menos a 300.000 kilómetros de
distancia
pensemos que la luna estaba a 50 mil
kilómetros que les faltaba para llegar
uno de los astronautas llamado hey se
toma un visor su visor donald se asoma
por la escotilla y observa el espléndido
escenario
tiene que compartir le llama su
comandante del lobelle le dice límite y
en el que beso el astronauta james
loader con un guiño de complicidad y con
una sensación de logro pensaba que ese
escenario no le iba a ser tan
desconocido porque ya lo había formado
en su cabeza producto de su gran
capacitación y de su gran entrega por
este proyecto
pero de pronto empieza el gran accidente
de la columna
uno de los motores los motores empiezan
a apagar el tanque de oxígeno explota y
deja la polo 13 sin oxígeno suspendido
en el espacio y desconectado desde su
base espacial
cuando de pronto a 320 mil kilómetros se
escucha cuando empiezan a tener de nuevo
conexión con el piedra
houston wi harper se acuerdan de esa
famosa frase que el cine inmortalizó no
era más que un llamado de auxilio desde
aquel lugar de un espacio del lugar lo
obscuro y suspendido en el espacio de
ayuda a su equipo de trabajo cómo le
hacemos que sigue por donde nos vamos no
había un plan de regreso en esas
condiciones el plan estaba diseñado pues
para que fueran a la luna y regresaran
tuvieron que tomar decisiones tuvieron
que sacar el conocimiento la casta
tenían que cambiar el objetivo el sueño
de pisar la luna se había esfumado y
ahora el gran objetivo pues era regresar
esos tres astronautas a tierra y lo
lograron por eso es que se llama el
accidente del apolo 13 se llama el
fracaso exitoso de la historia espacial
pero bueno por donde empezamos que es lo
que sucede cuando cuando nosotros
estamos capacitadas
vamos qué les parece si hablamos hoy del
encuentro de esa teoría del encuentro de
los grandes encuentros que tenemos con
la vida y vamos hablando del propósito
pero el propósito como un plan mayor
la teoría que yo sigo es que los libros
las personas las palabras las
oportunidades pero sobre todo nuestro
propósito no se encuentra lo que tenemos
que hacer es estar preparados alineados
capacitados con un visor bien ajustado
para que podamos identificarlo y
cercaron nuestra vida
cuando los accionantes del apolo 11
llegaron a tierra después de haber
cambiado el rumbo de la historia de la
ciencia y de la humanidad habían pisado
por primera vez la luna y los
astronautas del apolo 11 viajaron 400
mil kilómetros a encontrarse con su
propósito
al regresar a casa algunos de ellos
decidieron aislarse otros se deprimieron
empezaron a beber porque tal vez estaban
tan preparados para el encuentro con el
propósito se enfocaron tanto en eso y no
se prepararon probablemente para tomarlo
de la mano y vivir por él y para él esto
es a lo que me refiero de estar listos
para el encuentro con nuestro propósito
que sigue cómo le hago como le doy
significado y mejor aún como lo pongo al
servicio de las personas porque el
propósito es y debe ser compartido
y bueno que es el propio
este es este tema es un tema muy pues
muy comentado para mí el propósito si me
permiten compartir se lo agradeceré esas
frases filosóficas de algo que viene al
mundo para mí el propósito de ser el
presente un presente que tengo en las
manos y que soy capaz de regalarle al
futuro
el propósito debe ser y debemos
identificar esa sensación de que hay
algo mucho más grande que nosotros
mismos es un plan mayor que nos pide
sumarnos que nos pide poner nuestros
talentos y compartirlo con las personas
probablemente el encuentro con nuestro
propósito ya se dio y está ahí nos ha
tocado la puerta varias veces pero
probablemente no lo hemos identificado
porque a lo mejor no teníamos bien
ajustado ese ese visor con nuestro amor
y listos o no era nuestro momento para
tomarlo de la mano
existen personas muy inspiradoras
grandes personas que hablan que
admiramos por tus propósitos por sus
valores por sus metas por su coherencia
también hay marcas inspiradoras que es
una marca inspiradora pero también hay
agentes de cambio los agentes de cambio
son aquellas personas que logran
convertir un sueño en una meta una meta
en un propósito y un propósito en un
plan mayor para compartir
es como dijo de la zona ustedes lo ven
no o sea a partir de hoy a partir de
este momento pisar la luna se ha
convertido en nuestra gran
responsabilidad la responsabilidad que
tienen esos agentes de cambio como un
mark zuckenberg ol disney de james
cameron dalai lama su gran
responsabilidad es comparten con
nosotros en tecnología innovación
creatividad filosofía de vida pero su
gran responsabilidad es tomar de la mano
este propósito mantenido de nómina
te platico cómo veo el proceso hoy
estamos aquí con el gran tema de
evolución por el gran tema de que sigue
coleando porque hay muchos conceptos y
nadie tenemos la fórmula perfecta lo que
aquí es un momento y un lugar en donde
podemos inspirarnos y pensar en nuestra
propia forma
te platico cómo ve el proceso todos
iniciamos con un plan a
mi plan a fue el diseño gracias al
diseño yo entré al mundo de la
comunicación y de la publicidad pero
empecé a tener esa sensación de que
había algo más grande que yo mismo que
había algo más en lo que me podía sumar
y que desde mi trinchera del diseño no
me va a lograr empecé a engañar me
empecé a capacitar a buscar a escuchar a
buscar mentores a prepararme para ese
plan mayor que yo sabía que estaba ahí
y me encontré con mi plan de que fue el
marketing desde el marketing me di
cuenta que podía ser mucho más en el
marketing gracias al marketing yo empecé
a identificar que mi propósito era
comunicar y conectar a las personas con
las marcas pero mi gran responsabilidad
en el marketing es agregar agregar valor
a lo que hago y a lo que digo
y sobre lo que trabajo
y de pronto empecé a sentir otra vez
otro proceso otro otro pasito de
evolución en el que dije hay algo más
hay un nuevo plan al que me puedo sumar
hay un nuevo plan en el que te puedo
compartir y que a lo mejor puedo estar
más con un poco de aponiente mis
talentos y me encontré con el propósito
de comunicar me podía conectar con
personas de una manera más grande y
positiva tiene travel mundo del coaching
de las marcas de las charlas eso es lo
que para mí ha sido mi propósito y para
mí ha sido como parte de mi evolución
tengo que seguir trabajando tengo que
seguir haciendo todo el esfuerzo que
debo hacer para estar listo
les platico cómo puede ser el supuesto
cinco pasos que para mí son importantes
y creo que quiero compartir se los el
día de hoy para estar preparados para el
encuentro con nuestro propósito y para
estar preparados para sanar el primero
es hay que ser experto sea un experto en
juárez a más que te gusta que te con que
te den citas entre más expertos se hacen
su área
tu voz va a ser mucho más escuchada el
punto número dos es hay que diseñar un
plan de vuelo hay que diseñar un plan
ángulo pensando en uno en hornos en el
espacio sus débiles hay que tener un
plan con objetivos con estrategias se
ponen indicadores pero en este momento
tenemos que saber que los planes deben
adaptarse al contexto deben ser
flexibles y deben estar listos para
adaptarse el punto número 13 es
liderazgo claro
un buen líder es el que nos va a llevar
a donde queremos ir pero un gran líder
es el que nos va a llevar a lo mejor no
a donde queremos ir a donde debemos a
donde debemos estar los propósitos se
vuelven poderosos gracias a los grandes
líderes pero hay que liderar desde el
amor desde la empatía desde el servicio
desde ahí es donde debemos liderar para
que nuestro propósito tenga significado
el punto número 4 es abrazar su
propósito con responsabilidad la
responsabilidad de sambor las
responsabilidades compartir la
responsabilidad es compromiso si yo
estoy dispuesto a compartir mi propósito
personal a un plan mayor o de subir uno
para una mayor e invitar a las personas
tengo que tener la responsabilidad de
tomar y mantener realidad y el último
punto es disfrutemos el trayecto las
cosas llegan a no se me puede dar break
que disfrutar que el proceso sea sea
fascinante no estresada
hoy estamos hablando del propósito como
un plan mayor que un plato para
compartir y un propósito que nos
necesita que requiere de nuestros
talentos que identifiquemos cómo podemos
sumar nuestros talentos y nuestro
propósito individual y personal a un
plan mayor es la manera en la que
podemos evolucionar para que funcionar
picando transformados
si hay que querer más hoy más que nunca
tenemos que saber hay que identificar
todos esos grandes encuentros hoy más
que nunca sabemos que tenemos que
estirar a las personas a que se sumen a
que salgamos juntos adelante por un
sueño hoy más que nunca tenemos que
pensar en un enfoque porque tenemos que
tener un plan en la ruta bien bien
estructurada bien visualizada y de darla
con amor o pasión y con con certeza
hay que hay que saber que se vale y hay
que soñar pero hay que soñar en luchar
hay una gran diferencia entre luchar
entre sueños y leer por los sueños se
anhela por las metas se lucha pero por
el propósito se vive y cuando tu
propósito tiene cuenta asegúrate de
estar listo para pisar ganar muchísimas
gracias por este maravilloso encuentro
gracias